tahina deux ans et demi et luan trois
ans sont venus avec leurs mamans elles
ont pu s'amuser sur différents stands
des activités proposées par les
auxiliaire puériculture de trappe lors
de la fête de la petite enfance c'est
pour découvrir les activités qui a
autour et puis quelqu'un rencontre aussi
ses petits amis de la crèche puisqu elle
à la crèche collective
ça nous a permis de découvrir en fait
des petits ateliers
notamment au niveau de la nourriture la
propreté
et puis là au niveau de la motricité je
suis venu parce que pour ma vie en fait
pour qu'elles s'amusent comme je savais
que c'était de l'activité pour les
enfants pour moi c'est l'idéal pour elle
un rendez vous destiné aussi aux futurs
parents sahara et alain attendent un
enfant au mois d'août ils viennent
chercher des informations notamment sur
les différentes structures d'accueil
attrape voit beaucoup de questions au
niveau du mode de garde parce que bah
quand on travaille on était assez
stressés sur comment on va à placer
l'enfant quand voilà comment fonctionne
une crèche
la vie des enfants dans la crèche
l'objectif c'était de montrer comment
entre parent né en femme on peut
partager des choses
en s'appuyant sur ce qu'on peut vivre
dans les établissements et puis aussi
d'expliquer aux nouveaux parents comment
ça se passe dans les structures ce
qu'ils peuvent y trouver rencontrer les
équipes est rassuré un moyen de pouvoir
répondre aux questions des parents une
nouvelle édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine